>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to the African
Middle East Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb.
I'm Chief of the Division, and
I'm delighted to see you all here
for a very special program
to celebrate Jewish
American Heritage Month.
Today, we're hosting Joan Nathan,
who, as our flyer points out,
is a world-famous author
of 11 cookbooks.
I have my own copy of Cooking
Provence - Four Generations
of Recipes and Traditions.
It's a fabulous book, and Joan
is well-known to all of us.
She has spoken here many times.
And today, she will be talking about
her new book, King Solomon's Table -
A Culinary Exploration of Jewish
Cooking from Around the World.
But before that, we always
do a little commercial
about our division.
And as most of you already
know, our division is made
up of three sections, the African,
the Near Eastern, Hebraic sections.
We're responsible for materials
from 78 different countries
in the Near East, Central
Asia, the [inaudible],
as well as from the entire continent
of Africa, North and Sub-Saharan.
And we're very active in acquiring
and developing collections,
briefing visitors coming from
all the countries of the regions,
for which we are responsible.
We also invite scholars and experts
who have researched and done work
in our areas of responsibility,
as Joan Nathan.
And she has been a
very frequent user
of our collections,
which is wonderful.
This is why we cherish her as
one of our very special patrons.
And we do so, so that people get a
better insight and a better sense
of what those countries are about,
what their culture is about,
what their history is about.
This is why we have these experts
who make our collections come
alive in our reading room.
And we certainly collect cookbooks,
and we have here the expert.
We have Connie Carter, who is here
with us, from the Business, Science,
and Technology, who single-handedly
has built this collection
of cookbooks from around the world
as one of the largest collection
of cookbooks in the
world on cooking.
And she's made some of the
most wonderful exhibits,
displays here at the Library, always
including a book of Joan Nathan.
So I mean she's -- Joan
has been everywhere,
not only in our reading
room, but in different parts
of the library and
in our collections.
So we're really delighted to have
her with us, to have Connie with us,
and now to introduce Joan Nathan, we
have our very own Sharon Horowitz,
the Senior Reference Librarian
in the Hebraic section,
who will be doing the introduction.
So Sharon?
>> Sharon Horowitz: Yes, yes, sorry.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mary-Jane.
Good afternoon, and
welcome to you all.
The -- my name is Sharon Horowitz.
As you heard, I'm the Reference
Librarian in the Hebraic section.
The Hebraic section marks its
beginning in 1912, with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew books
and pamphlets,
whose purchase was
made possible by a gift
from New York philanthropist
Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in Hebrew,
Yiddish, Ladino, Judeo-Persian,
and other Hebraic script languages.
The Hebraic section also includes
an important collection of Ge'ez,
Amharic, and Tigrinya, languages
of Ethiopia past and present.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we accomplish this second
goal is by holding lectures
and having programs such as the
one we are hosting here today.
One item of business
before we begin,
this event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal
question-and-answer period
after the lecture, at which
the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
But please be advised, your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the
question-and-answer period,
you are consenting to the
Library's possible reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
And also, I want to call
your attention to a display
of international Hebrew cookbooks
and some of Joan's cookbooks
that are in the -- toward the
front of the reading room.
Please look at them.
They were arranged
with the assistance
of my colleague, Dr. Anne Brener.
And now, a word about our speaker.
King Solomon's Table - A Culinary
Exploration of Jewish Cooking
from around the World, as you
heard, is Joan's 11th cookbook.
In it, she shows the global
influences on Jewish cuisine
and what makes Jewish
cooking unique.
As one reviewer wrote, the notes
accompanying each recipe are
as enriching as the
dishes themselves.
She is a culinary historian
and chronicler of Jewish cooks.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
join me in welcoming the Doyen
of Jewish cooking, Joan Nathan.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Nathan: Thank you, Sharon.
Can you all hear me?
Because I sometimes
have trouble hearing.
Is this -- can you hear now?
>> Yes.
>> Joan Nathan: Good, okay.
First of all, I want to apologize
that I had two books which I forgot.
One was for her because clearly the
publisher didn't send them to her,
and the other one was for me.
But that's okay because I can
talk without my wonderful book.
I love this place.
This is the place that I really
think of as home in Washington.
I spent a lot of time here
with my first few books,
the Jewish Holiday Kitchen.
I just spent -- I guess
I had more time then.
I don't know, or we didn't
have the Internet I guess.
I spent days and days in the stacks.
And in fact, on my birthday
every year, I liked --
I would go to the stacks.
This year, I came to hear
Anne Brener's fabulous talk
on Raphael [assumed spelling]
right in this exact room.
And it was just a wonderful
way to spend a birthday
to learn more about Raphael.
So this is my 11th
book, and I always say
that I don't think I could
have written the book
that I wrote last without
the book for it.
So this book is really
looking at Jewish food
around the world, how
it came together.
And because it's so popular all
of a sudden, I kind of think
that in a way Jewish and Israeli
food is trumping politics,
that it's way up there.
People might not agree with the
politics, but they like the food.
And I think that really
all over the world,
people are looking for the new.
They're looking for
great ethnic food,
and that's what we
really love so much.
And that's why there's so many new,
exciting restaurants
from all over the world.
Thank you for doing this.
So what -- the way that this
book started was I had written --
I had written a proposal for another
book, which was to be something
on modern Jewish cooking.
And I really wasn't that
interested in doing it,
but I don't think I ever
admitted it to myself.
So I took a trip to
India, and I was in Kochi,
which is, you know, Cochin.
And I went to a synagogue
there, and on the wall it said
that Jews had been there since
the time of King Solomon.
And I started thinking, wow,
since the time of King Solomon?
And so, I looked at
when King Solomon was.
It was about 1,000 BC if
there was a King Solomon.
There are two schools of thought.
There are some people who
think that he's really a myth,
and the myth of the one -- you
know, the wise man and the king
and that really there was no --
I mean I don't see how they can
think there was no first temple,
but they do.
Other people think that he was --
he did exist, and I'm
going to be with those.
Anyway, he's a great metaphor for
all that's wonderful and somebody
who really likes good food.
So what I did was I looked when --
1,000 BC, and I went straight to
an archaeologist named Eric Klein,
who many of you might know from GW.
And he said to me, why
don't you come with me
to an archaeological conference
in Baltimore, which I did.
And I met all the leading
archaeologists,
and they told me what
they've been finding on food.
And everybody told me to
read a book by Jean Bottero
on the oldest cuisine in
the world, which I did read.
It was from 1700 BCE,
and the book was --
the book was on a cuneiform tablet
written in Acadian on four tablets
that are all at the Sterling
Library at Yale University.
And the tablets had a -- these
44 recipes, but most of them were
for huge amounts of food.
And they were for the
gods because they were --
everybody believed in
gods in those days.
And -- but what was interesting for
me, there were -- mostly were stews.
There were some breads.
You couldn't really tell
what the recipes were.
But there was one recipe
for -- thank you --
for a soup, a borscht soup.
And then there were all
these other recipes.
And what I was interested,
what the ingredients were.
So if you look at the top of the --
the cover of the book right
there and you can see a bread.
It's an Ethiopian Sabbath bread.
And it's got these little
seeds on it, Nigella seeds,
that we're all rediscovering now.
But these are some of the
oldest seeds known to man.
Then there was sesame seeds.
Sesame seeds, if sesame
seeds were existing then,
it meant that sesame seeds
came from China already
and that they're the
first ground seed oil.
So they were ground into oil I'm
assuming, and if they were ground
into oil, you can bet
that another ingredient
that was there was chickpeas.
The chickpea, the hummus was there.
It wasn't as a recipe in this list,
but this was something
that was a gruel.
That's what everybody ate,
but as a gruel with protein
so that people ate that for
morning and very often for evening,
poor people especially, as they
still do in the Middle East.
And one thing that I've learned
since I've worked on the book was
that chickpeas have been around
for about 12,000 years in the area
so that everybody had hummus,
in case you're not aware
of the hummus wars.
Every single country had hummus,
and the Proverbs of Gilgamesh,
which are from about the same time,
and nobody's sure exactly when,
but they're certainly a lot
earlier than the 1700 BCE cookbook.
They mentioned chickpea flour,
and chickpea flour was what you
would have used in the winter.
And of course, now
everybody's so excited
because everybody that's
gluten-free is suddenly eating
chickpea pancakes.
And they think that they're 19th
century Italian called farinata
or they're 19th century
French called soca.
But they've been around
for thousands of years.
And so, I began to
realize a few things.
First of all, the timeline
of Judaism, you know, whether
or not it's exact is something else,
but also the timeline of foods.
There were -- I said
there were beets.
There were Swiss chard.
There were -- well, there's dill.
There were lots of
ingredients that were used then.
And the sesame seeds
made me realize --
well, something else
that an academic at --
no, the archivist of the Sterling
Library told me was that the plates,
the -- there were blue and white
plates from China, the same pattern
in China as in Cypress at that time.
So plates were going around, and
these blue and white also might --
we -- it's a surmise,
but probably is correct.
At some point, they were made in --
I know they were made
in Iraq or Babylonia.
Then they went north and eventually
came to Scandinavia, where they --
to this day, there's blue
and white Scandinavian china.
But what else went from Babylonia?
Cardamom went with it.
And so, cardamom appears in
cakes throughout Scandinavia
because I always think that the
spices are a byproduct really
or something easily
that you can carry
when you're shipping big things.
Anyway, so I looked at that.
Then I realized that
about 1,000 BCE,
there was this man named
Abraham, who lived in Or,
which isn't that far
away from Babylonia.
How many miles?
She knows by heart,
about 300 miles I think.
Anyway, and so Abraham, remember
he took the idols and broke them.
He was a monotheist.
And so, he went on to the land of
Canaan with his people, with his --
I think he was sort of one of
the early communes with his wife,
his cousins, his friends,
and they set up --
they moved to the land of Canaan.
And then we know from the Bible
the foods that he found there,
which I'm sure he had
early on in the land of --
in Babylonia because this was
the Tigris and Euphrates were
in the Fertile Crescent, and
there was so much growing there.
So he went and he found these seven
ingredients in the land of Canaan.
He found barley, wheat, figs, dates,
olives, grapes, and pomegranates.
In addition, he found chickpeas.
He found lentils.
And he probably found fava
beans, although they --
well, he would have
found them by then.
So these were things that -- basic
foods that people had at that time.
And I also realized that when the
Jews went, of course, to Egypt,
then they came back and
built the first temple,
which was with King
Solomon, after King David.
And the reason that I call the book
King Solomon's Table were a number
of things.
First of all, in the Book of
Kings, it says that the 12 tribes
of Israel had to tie -- were
tithed or had to tithe the king,
King Solomon, with foods and also
jewels and stones and peacocks,
which they got -- I know that that
was one of the things they got.
And it was written from India
that they found them
as far East as India.
So each month of the year, there was
one group that was tithing the king.
In addition, King Solomon,
who as we all know was wise,
he also certainly had appetites.
He had 700 wives and 300 concubines.
So each of these women would
have brought with her food.
I mean there probably were not 700.
But anyway, that's why some
people think he doesn't exist.
You know, it's too many wives.
Anyway, but if you go to a Buddhist
temple anywhere in the East,
you see the temple or
the kingdom up top,
and then in the front you'll
see places for the concubines.
And I realized it was a
sign of power to have lots
of wives and lots of concubines.
Anyway, so to me King Solomon, his
wives brought in all the spices,
all the different foods, because
you would bring that from home.
Wouldn't you?
You would bring what
you were familiar
with if you were going
someplace new.
And so, there were all kinds of
flavors going on at his -- in --
at his temple and also at his
palace, which was also on the --
you know, it was on the
Mount, the Temple Mount.
And I also knew from the Phoenicians
that the Jews learned how
to use day boats, which
were wooden boats.
And they would have been
young boys probably.
I don't think anybody else would
have done this, that would have gone
out and have gone as far as
India and went -- was near --
were near India, and they would
see all the different foods
that were growing right
on like the ginger
and the cardamom and the pepper.
So they'd see these spices
that were so valuable
and also were transportable.
And they would gather them.
Some of them would meet women there.
They'd marry them, or they'd at
least have children with them.
And they would stay.
Others would leave.
In the 12th century, one of those
little villages that I went to,
Shanondaglom [assumed
spelling] I think it's called,
there was a synagogue.
Well, you can bet that there
was an earlier synagogue,
and I say that because when I wrote
the book of the food of the Jews
of France, the one that Mary-Jane
likes so much, when I wrote that,
I realized that there were
about 150 Jewish villages
or villages that had Jews.
They weren't Jewish villages
in the South of France
in the 1st and 2nd century AD.
And these were all
destroyed, and the only thing
that might have been
left and then some
of them would be a cemetery stone
or maybe an indentation in stone
where a -- what do you call it?
-- a mezuzah had been
so that things --
and I know that one person who
has studied Indian history a lot
and has used this library a lot
at first did not agree with me.
And he said, you know what?
You might be right, because he kept
saying unless you see an example
of somebody being there, how do
you know that they were there?
Well, history is a long time.
And we're -- you know, a lot
of these places get floods
and all kinds of things, but anyway.
And there were one -- you know,
there were hints here and there
that make you realize that
of course they came there.
So that was helpful to me.
And then I realized that after the
destruction of the first temple,
many Jews went to Babylonia.
And they stayed.
And so, then they went at about that
time on the Silk Route to the right.
I keep saying the right
and the left.
But anyway, on the Silk Route, they
went to places like Azerbaijan,
to Georgia, to just all the way,
all the way around up into Russia
and eventually to Poland.
So there's one group
that's going around.
Then another group went later after
the destruction of the second temple
through Egypt to Rome up to
France to Italy to Spain.
And then from Spain, they also went
east in the 14th and 15h century
through Alsace-Lorraine to
Poland and Eastern Europe.
So you find a conglomeration
of people all over the place,
and to me, that was
really interesting
because it was reflected
in the food.
So I felt that learning about Iraqi
food was very, very important.
So I went to -- I couldn't
go to Iraq.
And what I like to do is get
stories about people and food.
So I went to London, where I was
told the best Iraqi cooks are.
And I met with a woman named
Aileen Kolachi [assumed spelling]
and who's way in her 80s.
And she showed me how
to make macaroons.
Macaroons started in Babylonia.
Escabeche started there.
You can see through people where
it wandered throughout the world.
An overnight chicken
called tabit started there.
And people eating, you know, in the
ancient world, chicken came late
as far as being not -- there
were kinds of chickens, but as --
the way that we eat it is --
first of all, it's really late
because we had the --
remember those broilers?
That's from about the
'30s, the smaller chickens.
Bigger chickens were there, but
chickens -- hens were not eaten.
You would take a hen
that stopped laying eggs,
because that's why you had hens.
Then you would slaughter
it and eat it.
You would not take a young
chicken to slaughter and eat it.
And the same with cocks
were used for cock fighting.
And when they were too
old for cock fighting,
you would make cockova
or something like that.
Now -- and the rabbis would not
allow Jews, but this is much later,
to use cocks for fighting.
Anyway, so there -- in
the rabbinic literature,
it says that in the first century
AD the rabbis would not let Jews use
chickens for cooking because they
pecked around and they were dirty.
But later, of course, they did.
But they let them eat
them in Babylonia.
So you have this dish called tabit.
If I had a copy of the book, I
would read this wonderful quote.
Is there -- is the book
-- there are books, right?
Just give me -- thank you.
So the tabit was meant an
overnight cooked chicken,
and I wanted to learn
how to make it.
So there was this man named
Mayer Sofer [assumed spelling],
who might I'm sure came to this
library who lived in Virginia.
And -- thank you so much.
And he said to me, I will --
I'll show you how to make it.
So I went with him to his
house, and I went with one
of the Israeli ambassadors'
wives, who wanted to go shopping
in Tyson's Corner,
and I said, "Look,
we'll learn to make a chicken
recipe, and then we'll go
to shopping, to Bloomingdale's
or wherever."
So we went to -- and she
was in her finery, right?
So we walk into this man's
house, and he takes --
he says to her, "Do
you know how to sew?"
And she said, "Yes."
And so, he had skinned the chicken
already, and she took the --
he took the skin of the chicken, and
he showed her how to make pockets
that she could put the rice in.
And she really gave me a dirty look.
But anyway, so she was
-- needless to say,
we never got on our shopping spree.
[ Laughter ]
But we -- I learned this
really complicated recipe
that was cooked overnight,
and it was delicious.
Then I realized, well, wait
a minute, people are going
to want to make this recipe.
There are a lot of
quick ways to do it.
So then I went to visit
Aileen Kolachi,
and she showed me how she makes it.
And I'll just read to you
what I learned from her,
which makes -- oh, my glasses.
Are they right -- does anybody have
reader glasses I could just borrow?
Thank you so much.
So -- and this is what makes doing
the kind of work I do so much fun.
On a recent trip to London,
I visited Aileen Dangor
Kolache [assumed spelling],
one of those naturally
great cooks who lives
in an apartment overlooking
Baker Street.
Aileen, now in her late '80s,
may have left Baghdad in 1975,
but the family dishes decorated with
rosebuds and fragrant with cinnamon,
cloves, nutmeg, cardamom,
and turmeric remain
in her thoughts and
perfume her kitchen.
During a delightful day, I learned
recipes and listened to stories
about Aileen's early life when
some 20 people, mostly family,
when family meant everything,
lived in a big house
overlooking the Tigris River.
"At home we used the rice
my husband's family grew,"
Aileen told me in her kitchen.
"The rice often had
small stones in it,
so we had to clean it
before we washed it.
Then we washed it again, and again.
The rice we get today is clean, but
we Iraqis still wash it three times
and soak it for a few hours.
In Baghdad, we only ate fruits
and vegetables in season,
so we had to make and store what
we needed for the whole year.
We even made tomato puree
for our cooking," she added.
"In the summer, everybody
bought a lot of tomatoes,
squeezed the juice out, sieved
them to remove the seeds
and the outer skin, and put the
juice in a big container on the roof
of the house and kept
it there for a few days
in the sun until it became thick.
Friday was the day to start tabit.
There were no home ovens
at that time in Baghdad,
so the tabit was cooked on charcoal
overnight for Sabbath lunch.
On top of the cover, we
put eggs in their shells,
then covered it again," she said.
"On top of everything was a
folded blanket to keep the heat.
We ate the eggs Saturday
morning with tomatoes, onions,
and lemon salad, with pickles
or spring onions and parsley."
Today, most cooks have learned
speedier ways to make tabit
than the one I described above.
When I make it, I follow
some traditional customs
like using fresh spices I grind and
cleaning the chicken with a lemon.
Also, I make sure to produce
enough hakaka [assumed spelling],
known in Iran as tahdig, the
prized crust of rust that forms
on the bottom of the casserole.
So, you know, images like that you
don't get by talking on the phone
with people to get a recipe.
You have to spend a
whole day at least
because there's a lot
that comes out.
And I did that with women in Italy.
With this woman, I learned a lot of
recipes from her and other things
that make what you're doing
so very, very special.
And then -- and then I realized
that so much of this Iraqi food
or Baghdadi food or Babylonian
food spread throughout the world,
even though they had people that
came in that other conquerors,
it was such a strong
commercial center that it's --
when almost to the 8th century,
it just was people
wanted to live there.
It was a fertile region.
It was a crossroads.
And the Jews started something
called the Radonites [assumed
spelling], and the Radonites were
a group of traders that went as far
as Russia, as far as China, and
they were a network of people
that would -- of merchants
that would start
with food, with buying spices.
They'd buy gems.
They'd buy -- I heard
they bought fish.
I don't know how they carried live
fish, but supposedly they did,
all the way around the world with --
and it was in a way
like a relay race.
And the known verbiage -- of course,
the known language was Hebrew.
But there of -- they were not
the only groups, of course.
I'm just talking about one group.
This -- what I'm saying
could be said about a lot
of different people
within that region.
But there was one thing that made
them different from everybody else,
and that was their food
and their laws of religion.
So for me, there are three
different ways of defining --
or three characteristics
of Jewish food.
One of them, of course,
is the dietary laws,
no question about that.
Even if in the back of
your mind you don't believe
in the dietary laws,
it's still there.
And all the -- all the laws
of Judaism are still there.
So that's number one.
And also, this obsessiveness about
food, I mean believe me, it is.
But I guess we're all
obsessed about food.
So then the second one is this
merchant part of Judaism that just
as they looked for ingredients
in India in those ancient times,
Jews have always been merchants
and have always been looking
for the new, maybe for the
new for themselves, the new --
they've always been merchants.
And that -- you can trace
that all over the world.
You know, they were the first ones
to think of futures in the sense
that if you buy grain when it's
first harvested and you hold it,
when you buy it when
it's first harvested,
there's a lot of grain, right?
If you hold it to the winter,
there's not so much grain
so that you can raise the prices.
And that's what a lot of people
in the stock exchange learned
from Jewish merchants, that this
is the way things had to go.
The -- I just -- there are bakers.
There's a disproportionate number
of bakers within Jewish communities
because -- and just even
look in Washington today,
Mark Furstenberg at Bread Furst.
And cooks, there are a lot of
Jewish chefs too right now.
But I have a theory about that,
which I'll tell you later.
Anyway, so the second one was the
merchant and the interest in food.
The third is the fact that Jews
were kicked out of so many places.
So they had to adapt their cuisine
to different regions always.
And I think some of you
are nodding your heads.
I'm sure that Indians and Lebanese
and all kinds of -- Chinese --
have also had to adapt theirs.
But the point is that
you want to have the --
food is comfort, and you want to
have this table-centered religion
as comfort with the foods
that you grew up with.
And I'll give you an example.
I was -- for the book, I went to El
Salvador to interview the 100 people
in the Jewish community
of El Salvador.
And there was this one
woman, and they all made food
for me for Friday night dinner.
And a woman made yucca
latkes with cilantro cream.
Well, yucca is easier to get
in El Salvador than potatoes.
And so, that's what she used.
And, you know, and you find
that over and over again.
I found escabeche, which is a fried
and marinated fish, in Jamaica.
And what do they serve it with?
Scotch bonnet peppers
because -- and also allspice.
Now allspice too, so what I did in
this book was I took the timeline
of Jewish history, and I tried
to combine it with ingredients.
So when I went to Spain
and then I went
to the New World, I
realized a few things.
First of all, the -- 1492 being
the time when the Jews had to get
out of Spain, it was no coincidence
that Christopher Columbus had
his boat that started in 1492
because for the eight years prior
to that, all the boats were rented
for Jews that wanted to get out.
They had a big -- there
were like 250,000 Jews
in Spain, and they had a deadline.
So they got out.
When Christopher Columbus, well,
went, there were certainly Jews
that were on the boats and
that stayed in the New World.
And then they brought back or else
other people brought back to Jews
that were called Turkish merchants.
They were originally Sephardic
merchants, but they didn't want
to be called Sephardic because
they knew they were being kicked
out of Spain.
There were also Portuguese
that were called
in France Mershon [assumed
spelling] Portuguese,
and they were Portuguese merchants
that were also taking
these ingredients
and bringing them to places.
Well, first of all, they came to
Naples, which was a Spanish port.
But then they went -- like,
corn, peppers, tomatoes,
and I forget what other
one, potatoes --
went to places like
Bulgaria and Hungary,
always by the so-called
Turkish merchants.
And this was a fertile
area of the Danube River.
So they planted them.
Most of those things were used
for fodder at the beginning,
and then eventually, like Jerusalem
artichokes, people liked using them.
But the potatoes, they
were just grown
for farms, that's it, not to eat.
And even when my father, who
came from Germany in 1929,
when he came to the United States
and there was all this good
corn, he wouldn't eat it.
He said that's just for animals.
So I guess in Southern Germany, they
didn't have really good corn then.
So I realized that -- and the
other thing that I realized
in the centuries before
where foods went.
Where foods went were very easy
for me to figure out their roots
because you can see
there's a lot written on it.
And -- but it's really
interesting to trace it,
and you'll see it in my book.
But the other thing that
was a big, big help to me,
and I'm doing all this academic
stuff because this is the Library
of Congress, is -- was
the Genizah in Cambridge.
So I went there, and
I was really lucky
because then Woodwright [assumed
spelling], who was the archivist,
spent a lot of time with me
telling me about the ephemera.
Do you know -- does everybody
here know what the Genizah is?
It's this -- you do, or you don't?
Okay. So a genizah were like
a treasure chest of documents.
They say they were
in Christian churches
and mosques and in synagogues.
And they -- they're lost
documents of ephemera mostly.
But they're supposed to keep
everything that was written
on sheepskin or paper with
the name of God in it.
And they found one of these treasure
chests in the Cairo synagogue
in about the end of
the 19th century.
And I mean it's -- there's a
wonderful book called Sacred Trash
that if any of you want to
read, you'll read about the --
it's a wonderful detective story
about how all this stuff was found
and then how you read
about different people.
And there were letters so
that I learned, for example,
that there was a -- remember I
said that there's like a relay race
from Aden to Cairo, or
it was called Fustat,
which is part of Cairo today.
And then some went to
Ceylon, these boats.
And then a lot of the heads of the
boats would write these letters,
and they would say -- write one
letter to another merchant saying,
"I slipped in some turmeric
and other spices so that the --
so you wouldn't have
to pay tariff on them."
And you knew that these
were from men for,
you know, the -- for virility.
And it's really interesting
to see what went
on just in what they wrote.
And this was a way of endearing
one merchant to another merchant,
or there was wheat sent
to a community in Aden
because they didn't
have wheat at the time.
And, you know, you're supposed
to make a wheat challah
on Friday night.
So you got senses, or
one I have in my book,
a woman who was a lousy cook,
and her husband went out,
and this was what you
learned what people did.
He had the shopping list because
a lot of the women were kept in --
they were in their
courtyards or at home.
They didn't go out.
And it was a way of a man
saying, look, I made the money.
So he would go out like on a
Wednesday because it was --
you wanted to have food for Shabbat.
He would go -- when he got his
paycheck, if it was Wednesday
or Thursday, he'd come after work,
go to the market, and you can see it
like in Machneyuda
in Jerusalem today.
Go there, he'd buy the
ingredients that she said,
and he'd bring them home.
So he had this one recipe,
this man who wrote a lot
about his wife being
a terrible wife.
But my editor made me take it out.
I don't know why.
Anyway, so -- but she could cook.
So he had this one recipe for
Shavuot, one hen for the Sabbath,
eggplant, and some other things.
So I looked in old books because
I realized that most things --
you know, that people didn't
have different like a vegetable
on one side, and that came later.
They would have a stew pretty much.
That's what you would have
for your dishes, or, you know,
a stew like a couscous, where
you'd have rice and you'd have --
anyway, so I looked in old, old
cookbooks for chicken with eggplant,
and I had never known
that as a Sabbath dish.
And there it was in all
of these Iraqi cookbooks
and also different
Sephardic cookbooks.
And you realize a lot of the people
that came to Spain came through Iraq
so that -- and I'm convinced
that they went back to Iraq maybe
after 400 years because
they still --
when they were kicked out of Spain,
when they still had relatives there.
And then they went around the world.
So, you know, and then
they went to India,
because I met this woman named
Queenie Halegwa [assumed spelling]
in Kochi, and she invited
me for dinner.
And she kept talking about pastel.
And her -- and I thought, wait a
minute, this woman is not Sephardic.
She's really Iraqi.
And her son said the same thing.
He said, "I think that
our family was in Spain.
They came back, but
she liked that pastel,
which is like a pastry
filled with things."
Oh, there are many
different kinds of pastels.
And then brought it back to --
hit comes in families, right,
these words and these recipes.
The other thing is there's no -- in
the Genizah, there are no recipes.
There are shopping lists, and
then there are prescriptions
from doctors, like Mimodenes
[assumed spelling] would have
written you need this -- you
need chicken and chicken soup.
And so they would talk
about different ingredients
that you would need.
So the Genizah's really interesting.
So please read that.
So -- and then of course, food
has changed tremendously today,
and that's because
of the world of 1850s
on where we have all this rich
food and the processed food.
The Age of Industrialization
changed everything
and changed it very quickly.
I'm convinced that in the ancient
world, it took a lot longer time
to -- for food to change.
For us, it's within weeks.
We've got email.
We have radio, TV, cook --
how many cookbooks do we have?
But it used to be that
you would learn it
from your mother, from your family.
In a way, it was like
the closed communities
of today, but just family units.
And that's -- and people would
in different countries
guard their foods
so preciously within the community.
And I've gone way beyond
my speaking.
Okay. So you can look at my book.
I hope you will like it.
It's got recipes from
all over the world.
And I've gone to a lot of
places to get these recipes.
I've got -- and I'd love to see
if any of you have any questions
because we can -- then I can answer
talking about some of my recipes.
Tamara [assumed spelling],
you'd better ask
about your mom, your father.
>> Tamara: My father?
>> Joan Nathan: Yeah.
>> Tamara: My mother?
My mother's from Rome.
My father's from Bulgaria, and they
did have pastel [inaudible] pastel.
So I noticed when we spoke about it,
you talked about it
almost as a dessert.
They -- the way they would
cook pastel using eggplant
and ground beef, so I
wonder if you can --
>> Joan Nathan: Okay, so that --
yeah, well, that's in my book,
that recipe from your -- okay,
so what she asked the pastel
that her father talked about was
different from what I'm saying.
A pastel can be a pie, a meat pie.
And Tamara's sister, she's
related to my husband,
but her sister gave me two
amazing recipes from the family.
And one of them -- I mean
her father's family thinks
that they came -- they're
direct descendants --
I hate to tell you a lot of people
think that -- of King David.
So she had a challah recipe that
is so good, that is so wonderful
that you can see that
it went to the Balkans.
It came from Spain up to
the Balkans to New York,
and now her sister's
living in Israel.
So -- oh, and Italy,
she lived in Italy.
So it picks up things, like
her kids like hot dogs.
Hot dogs are in it.
She's got eggplant because
they lived in Bulgaria.
Eggplant is in it.
And these -- that's what's
wonderful about recipes.
The pastel that she has,
which is really delicious.
I'm telling you.
It's got eggplant and meat and
ground beef and I think tomato.
And you make it -- I
make it with puff pastry.
I think that's what she
said to do, or no, no, no.
I do not make it with puff pastry.
I tell you, you can.
It's a really easy pastry, and
then you put it on the bottom,
put this in, you know, and cover it.
Delicious.
Everybody loved it when I made it.
So it's one of the great
recipes of the book.
Any other -- hi.
>> Audience Member: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It was very exciting.
I'm looking forward
to reading your book.
I wanted to ask you.
Since you were traveling with
the food, what was being used
to preserve the food,
for example, the fish
or the vegetables or whatever?
What are their spices
that are useful
for preserving or for
cooking things?
>> Joan Nathan: Okay.
Well this is a really good question.
What spices or what ways
of preserving things?
Well, the ways were, you
know, very, very old.
Salting was the primary
one, and that's why salt
in a way was so precious.
You could salt fish.
You could salt vegetables.
You could -- vegetables, though, the
best way to preserve was in the sun.
And just the way they took these
tomatoes and put them on the roof,
and they do that to this day.
I was in a little village in
Galilee, an Arab village in Galilee,
and they were drying their
wheat on the top of the --
for Balger [assumed
spelling] on the top of roofs.
So that -- you know, that's --
and of course, salting fish,
salting fish, but also
putting it in vinegar.
A lot of vegetables were either
dried, or the Italian Jews,
for example, they would
pickle their zucchini.
But Turkish Jews would salt
it -- I mean, excuse me,
dry it and then I'm sure
you've seen eggplant
and zucchini put on long strings.
So there were different ways,
and this was so important.
The Bedouins to this day still salt
their yogurt to make it into fish.
I mean excuse me, to
make it into cheese.
So it's very dry, and
it's very salty.
So you dehydrate it, and
it won't be as salty.
And you can use it in
the winter as cheese.
Yeah, so -- and then as far
as spices, I'll tell you this.
I think it's an interesting story.
The spice allspice was
from -- is from Jamaica.
So I think that allspice came to
England, was called English pepper,
and there was another ingredient
called cubeb, which was a little bit
like allspice, a little bit like
pepper, a little bit grainier.
And that was used until
allspice, which is very much used
in the Middle East, came
down to Babylonia from --
or to Baghdad from England,
and it just wiped it out.
No one uses cubeb anymore.
But I have a feeling cubeb
might -- it's like a berry.
It might be Sancho
pepper, and I'm not sure.
Anyway, but -- so that
things change.
Yeah. Yes?
>> Audience Member: You mentioned
that the early dishes
were largely stews.
This would sort of fit in with
ceramic like pottery-type stuff
that would only take indirect heat.
But in all of your many, many,
many studies, what is something
about the history of
where it was used?
When did metal come in for
the Jewish communities?
>> Joan Nathan: When did what?
>> Audience Member:
When did metal cookware?
>> Joan Nathan: Oh, well --
>> Audience Member: Ceramic
crockery type things.
>> Joan Nathan: I mean
it came in late.
You know, it was used
like iron was used first.
That was used very early,
probably, I don't know,
12th century, maybe earlier.
But a lot of metal came at
the Age of Industrialization.
You know, we were this --
last summer, my husband and
I went to -- where was it?
Marquette, Michigan.
Have any of you ever been there?
And there's this huge iron ore --
it's like an elevated iron ore --
I don't know what it is,
to load the iron ore.
It's maybe 30 -- it's as high
as this -- as this ceiling.
And you load -- they would come,
and trains would go up to the top,
and they'd load the iron ore,
little pellets that they made.
And I realized that
this makes the --
and they would go down
to Benton Harbor
to make all the steel that we use.
And I realize how really late
processed all this stuff was.
It was just people
making it till then.
But it was, you know, I
mean individuals making it.
And the Age of Industrialization
just changed everything.
Yeah?
>> Audience Member: How many
countries are represented
in the book, as far as
[inaudible] countries?
>> Joan Nathan: How many
recipe -- how many countries?
Well, there are I think about 30
to 40 different countries
represented in the book.
And I could have -- now that
I'm speaking around the country,
I've learned that Azerbaijani, all
these people, I mean Azerbaijan is
in the book, but people are coming
to me with lots and lots of recipes.
They're coming to me
-- oh, they say Haiti.
There's a group of Jews
that lives in Haiti.
So I'm going to ask Jose
Andreas if I can go with him
to find these Jew -- I mean you
know, I'm -- it's so interesting.
I mean I always thought
that writing these books,
I would be bored after a while.
I'm never bored.
It's just -- you know, I get
all these letters about --
I drive Sharon crazy because I want
to find out if a Yiddish recipe,
we can find it here that I
can't find in any of my books.
But, you know, and at the Library of
Congress, I learned so many things.
For example, I forget.
Who was the man that knew
so much about the collection
who passed away of the --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What?
Myron Meinstein [assumed
spelling] was one,
but there was this other person.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
No. Anyway, but Myron would know.
For example, sauce Portuguese,
whenever you use a Portuguese sauce
in the early cookbooks, it
meant that it was a tomato sauce
and that it was a Jewish
tomato sauce because, again,
these Portuguese merchants.
And I'll tell you one quick story
about the Portuguese merchants.
They were very -- there was
always somebody who was a doctor
in the family -- in these
Portuguese families.
And there was one doctor named
John du Sucara [assumed spelling],
who I spent a lot of
time in the Library
of Congress before everything
was digitalized looking him
up and learning about him.
And he was the earliest
-- the only Jew living
in -- what do you call it?
Williamsburg, Virginia,
at the time Jefferson.
And you can see at Winter
Tour [assumed spelling] some
of his painting of him, and
somebody wrote on the back,
he introduced tomatoes to Virginia.
And there was this I think
apocryphal story that he was
with Thomas Jefferson, and they
were in Petersburg, Virginia,
and Thomas Jefferson started eating
a tomato because it was a member
of the nightshade family, right?
And so, everyone thought that
they were just to look pretty.
And he bit into it, and
everyone went [gasp].
And of course, he didn't die.
So people started eating tomatoes.
I don't -- I mean I've heard that
story from a lot of different towns.
So I'm not sure if it's true
or not, but I like the story.
Anyway, but he really introduced
them because he knew a --
because he was a scientist and
because he had the experience
of being a Jew and eating
these things, again,
within his insular family in London,
and it was a well-known family.
But he never married.
He started the Wine
Society in Williamsburg.
His house, you can still
see it, where he lived.
You know, it sounds
like he was a quiet man.
I'd love to learn more about it.
If any of you -- you
know more about him?
No? Okay. Another question?
>> Audience Member:
What's your theory
about why there are
so many Jewish chefs?
>> Joan Nathan: Ah,
oh, good question.
What's my theory about why
there's so many Jewish chefs?
Okay, in 1968, there was -- a
chef was a blue collar worker.
So remember Paul Prudone
[assumed spelling]
and this guy Louie
Sotmarie [assumed spelling]
from the bakery in Chicago?
They lobbied to change
the assignation of chef
from blue collar worker
to white collar worker,
which they did in 1968.
And it took a while, you know?
And all I could think of when
that happened, especially now
when there's so many Jewish
chefs, is that Jewish mothers
at that time wanted their sons
to go to be a doctor or a lawyer,
but now being a chef
has a lot of prestige.
So they were -- I mean I'm sort
of being ludicrous about this.
But I think in a way
it's a respected career,
and there are more
and more and more.
And I'm just amazed at it actually.
And also, the reception
of Jewish food, you know,
when I was very young,
it wasn't so popular.
Anyway, is there one more
question, or -- okay?
>> Audience Member: Did you
notice a major difference
between Ashkenazi Sephardic
and Mizrachi foods?
>> Joan Nathan: Oh, okay.
It was did I notice a big difference
between Ashkenazi Sephardic
and Mizrachi?
Mizrachi means in a
way everything else.
So Sephardic would mean
if a Jew went to Spain,
but if a Jew is --
still can be Iraqi.
In my book, I try not to use
the word Sephardic and Ashkenazi
because I think in a
way it's irrelevant.
It's sort of where
each family journeyed.
So I did find lots.
I mean I for sure more than any
other book because I went to --
I didn't -- I didn't
always have to go to places.
For example, there are a lot of
Azerbaijani Jews now in Brooklyn.
And there are Uzbeki Jews in
Brooklyn with really good food,
if you go to the families and
other places around the country.
So all I had to -- or
Iranian food in LA.
So I went there rather than
traveling around the world.
But I got some great int in
by the way, and in Israel,
I got a lot of great
recipes, Bulgaria.
Or you can get in Libyan
food, for example, which is --
would go with the Mizrachi.
You get that in Rome
and in -- and in Israel.
And you -- and you -- that's
one of the cuisines that's going
to really be going
because there's no --
there are no Jews anymore in Libya.
There are no Jews in Iraq.
So with all the intermarriage
between different kinds of Jews
and between Jews and
non-Jews, a wonderful cuisine
like Libyan food is harder to make.
And a -- it's going
to go by the wayside,
unless people like
me try to capture it.
But I really -- and what
I did when I tried to do
when I'm testing recipes, I test
them like on a Friday or Thursday
and Friday, like maybe
six or seven recipes.
And then I invite people
for Shabbat dinner.
And then they -- some
of them I really trust
because they'll be honest with me.
And I think would I ever
want to make this again?
Because you -- I'm writing
a cookbook for people,
and if you don't want to write --
you don't want to make that
recipe again, then forget it.
So that's what I do, and
it really works for me.
Some people send out the recipes,
but I like having a connection
to my books and to, you know, what's
in the books, and make it part
of my life because I can --
you know, you can always
tell the stories
that go behind all these recipes.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.